I'm down off $902 like five bucks I
think the idea of like what money means
to me has changed I passed that
milestone of like becoming a millionaire
late 2017 I think money doesn't mean too
much to me I don't think we need as much
of it as we think we do people do find
it hard to talk about money because it's
so private it's like talking about
underwear what is going on everyone it's
Ricky with long-planned profit uh
yesterday covered profits at 63-31
today during pre market hours it hit
highs of $69 my name is Ricky Gutierrez
I'm 23 years old and I live in Gilbert
Arizona what I do for a living is
investing in the stock market I'm an
influencer I own a series of real estate
properties and I run a series of online
businesses yeah so I put this year with
the different products that we have
going on I can probably bringing like 6
to 7 million
[Music]
my name is Azariah Randall and I'm 21
years old and I live in San Diego
California what do I do for a living I
primarily deliver food signed up for
this food delivery app I can make like
easily like a hundreds a day hope you
guys all have an amazing rest of your
day continue working hard to continue
fallen dreams let your passion be
rejection your success like ours guys
let's make sure that we in the year on a
green note take it easy team as in
trading not very good so I'm down about
1% in big picture like it's not much
it's just because I'm right now invested
with about $30,000 boom boom boom what's
going on guys I made a mistake and I
covered profits yesterday on you guys
and look what I missed out on
we have these here all right there I
have my other GTR over there I own that
house too my favorite part of the day is
working with my private group and seen
the excitement that they give back is
probably one of the most rewarding
things my goal is to create a series of
applications that are worth like
hundreds of millions if not billions of
dollars I think if I had ten billion
dollars in my pocket right now I think I
would still be the same person because I
have a stronger relationship with my
faith Matthew 6 and 21 says wherever
your treasure is the desires of your
heart will be also
what is going on everyone I'm gonna be
packaging some orders protect with
apparel just say you parents to Europe
yeah so they went for I think a total of
like twenty four days any time that is
that they like us or need something like
I'll be like paying my little sister's
tuition for her university and then
anytime that they like running though or
something then I can assist but what's
up Instagram you look it's a good day we
got we got John here he's following me
around all day pretending that my life
is interesting it might be dirty
[Music]
practices baby
oh we got a delivery
we got the text message we're going to
the broken yolk wages down here on six
[Music]
got one for two of us in here oh my gosh
like I'm down oh my god actually more
than I thought 902 dollars know because
I've been down like 2,000 dollars and it
recovers and I make like $3,000 on it so
[Music]
so right now as you can see we don't
have any deliveries so we're waiting
playing the waiting game it's kind of it
looks like when you text your crush and
then you're waiting for her it's
actually back but she never does how's
your hand that's tough in this position
I'm someone that like I value the dollar
someone like you somebody go to Chipotle
and I won't get a drink I just became
very frugal from a very early age and
very aware of how to try to make money
and the stress that it brings on and
seeing how it acted as a negative
catalyst for my parents relationship I
went to McDonald's and I overheard that
my parents weren't doing as well
financially and my cousin was like oh I
want a Big Mac and I want large fries I
like like today but I was like no don't
get that like you know just because of
the extra cost that's when I really
started to you know try to buy and sell
like sicker bars or power raids just to
pay for myself so my parents didn't have
to pay me well I was gonna pay like nine
bucks
aja walk let's go yeah yeah yeah to dr.
pepper seafood delight house egg rolls
and egg tarts ooh yeah awesome this
order is hella big waiting round two
when I was growing up we were we are
good financially up until my age like
seven I guess I would say that was when
my mom was like a single mom to me and
my two sisters we didn't know we were
poor or like broke or anything because
my mom did such a good job of hiding it
and just like grinding and hustling but
then like growing up I kind of did
understand like our financial hardships
look how much we got paid for that 35
bucks because that's like with a fat tip
and whatnot yeah exciting happen
she says she's missing an item yes I'm
so sorry yes there's another part of
your order we have it back here there's
three salads right okay thank you
to turn your passion for cars into
profit we are reopening the 30-day
flippin mules mentorship challenge we
showed that last time in three days all
you have to do now is swipe up to learn
more I got terrible news they don't have
the tomato and mozzarella panini but
they do have I think it's this building
right here is this 20 to 30 I know it's
been super slow for like an hour
probably won't get any more orders just
because we're downtown and everybody's
probably like on their way home already
right now yeah we'll just call it a day
[Music]
[Applause]
do you think that money defines people
weren't you to go to find to you I I
think I think in today's role money
definitely does have a a huge form of
credibility
I believe money can define you if you
let it
I don't believe it defines me personally
at all I've had like 27 cents in my bank
account and also have had like three
thousand dollars in my checking account
it was just like ready to ball out you
know and I was the same exact person
does money buy no that's when these are
on someone who does not buy happiness
one that's a quick one I'd say I know
definitely I'm very happy with there's
no reason not to be happy right with
hoarders that I am but there's
definitely moments that
feels like kind of like I know just like
empty
[Music]
I think money can buy happiness but it
can only buy either temporary happiness
or things that make you happy
I am I'm very happy it's it's weird I'm
like smiling answering that and like I
like struggle with depression and stuff
so it's weird but it's like like I'm
very freakin happy
[Music]
are you the net pushing him again
that's which i'm ricki today yeah with
everything I'd say probably around about
11,000 yeah you know continue working
hard to continue follow dreams like your
passion be what drives you and your
success and like always let's make sure
that way in the year on every note let's
go hey make some noise for me if you
broke all right y'all hesitated you're
all getting robbed by the end of this
set tonight today we made six while we
were out in like almost five hours which
is like 12 bucks an hour
I think minimum wage is like 11:50 I
would like to be making more money and
I'm trying to figure out ways to do that
people have lately been telling me I'm
plenty I found that out recently so
that's part of the reason I just started
doing stand-up comedy I can definitely
make people laugh
we've got the light I know right
he may have they but write the check
right the ching ching
so all my friends that guys with you
high school just right away to college
and I'm like dang they broke they like a
hundred twenty thousand in day I'm just
like two thousand in debt
he's moving so who won we did we'd all
read books you do me like